welcome everyone the time being 9:40 we
will get started on the public hearing
uh for uh sb12 FN amendment number 2023
um I guess um we' probably start with uh
representative ducet do you want to
introduce the
amendment good thank you Mr chairman
uh as we looked at this
at our last meeting what an
effect uh this amendment does is it puts
a
moratorium on
expanded uh
HHR and
eliminates the charge of rent for the
Charities to participate in charitable
gaming that's kind of it in a
nutshell I think uh we've all heard
testimony and some of us on on the uh on
the committee are involved with the the
chable gaming commission uh rent has
been a an issue for not only the
Charities but those of us uh who
recognize it's long past its its time
we've heard testimony that this was uh
the rank component was uh going back to
Inception of charal gaming the some
people referen the nights of
uh Casino nights and church basements to
you know make make the ends meet for
those folks that were operating those
and uh obviously with uh the Advent of
the model we have now and the expansion
of that model this is uh long overdue
eliminating this this rent
component secondarily to that the
moratorium on the HHR machine I think we
can all attest to the fact and I I know
specifically in my town the people I
represent in Salem um right now I
believe we have 14 or 15 charitable
gaming establishments in the state of
New
Hampshire uh which far exceeds the
totality of New England I think we have
a phenomenal model that benefits our
Charities but I think we've all
witnessed what's trans transpired since
the Advent of the HHR component that One
Singular game um with the lodger
operations coming in buying up rooms uh
taking over the space from the local
operators um there's been great interest
in my town of
Salem um and you've heard me say it
before I think uh now is the time to to
put uh put the breaks on this um I don't
want to particular turn Salem into
Atlantic City you've heard me say that
time and time again these operators are
are really pushing for this you can just
look at the expansion of for instance
any of the Border towns but the nashar
uh one particular room has
expanded
um you know we don't need to list them
all there's great benefit to the model
to Charities to the state and to The
Operators themselves but I think uh we
need to reel in what can get out of hand
relatively quick with this component
this does not negate anybody
from uh applying for and receiving a
charitable gaming operator's license uh
and as an
example uh in the last last I look last
five years of uh that I looked into it
back a little while ago there had been
no new applicants for charitable gaming
operators licenses in the last few
months there's been I believe director
McIntyre testified to four I'm hearing
rumors that may be five in the last few
months and and my opinion is that's a
direct component of the HHR game um and
I just hate to see us change the uh the
face of what the model we have in the
state is so I would I would ask for
support
on uh Amendment 2358
and and uh I do have an amendment to
that in in the component you you'll also
have in front of you I have an updated
uh more of a
friendly housekeeping Amendment 2444 H I
had missed uh Rick Newman had pointed
out to me I had missed in three
different paragraphs where rent was
mentioned in the statute so this
corrects that other than that there's no
changes this allows for
the four current applicants to uh
continue through the process with
Lottery and open up uh their operations
if they were approved so as it stands
now we have uh basically the possibility
of 19 charal gaming operations with HHR
so I submit that you know we we need to
put the breaks on this before it gets
out of hand thank you Mr
chair thank you and if you would out a
pink card later so we can have that for
the records that' be great okay I do
have one uh pink card in front of me um
forward thank you Mr chairman
uh my name is Rick Newman I'm
representing the New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators Association
we are here today to support the
proposed amendment to Senate Bill 112 um
and the other housekeeping parts that
were originally in Senate B 112 I'll be
very brief it's uh uh first I'll speak
to the subject of rent representative
ducet touched on it this bill would this
amendment would uh prohibit the uh
charging of rent to Charities uh we do
support that um uh rent was originally
put into the statute went back in a time
when the maximum bet was $2 in charity
gaming and it was very difficult for
operators to even make ends meet uh at
that level of Revenue later it was
increased to four and then in 10 and now
of course you folks have increased the
maximum bet to $50 and we believe that
there's no longer it's no longer
necessary that the rental charges be
included and this will benefit Charities
a great deal there be a significant
amount of additional Revenue to each
charity participating in games or chance
we also support um the second part that
is the major part of this bill which is
the um essentially uh creating a a
permanent moratorium beyond the those
who have applied or in the pipeline now
who might end up becoming a qualified
applicants as representative duet said
I've heard that uh it could be three or
four potential applicants that are going
through the process doesn't mean all of
them will qualify I don't know who they
are and uh but uh it seems to me that's
this is a reasonable approach to take to
uh put a uh so that we don't have on
July 1 of 2024 under the current law the
doors open up and we could have uh uh
historic horse racing in every strip
mall in every corner uh of the state I
don't think anybody thinks that's a good
idea thank you Mr chairman thank you any
questions representative
Aly thank you I'll ask one of the ones I
wanted to ask representative set on this
is something that's just been bothering
me from the beginning I haven't done
anything about uh the rights of the
leny do does charitable gaming in
general have the right to kick people
out well I think probably any business
has the right to tell someone to leave
The Establishment the it the the point
specific yeah this is is getting
specific because under current law other
paramutual licenses it is specific that
you can tell someone to leave and it's
at the sole discretion of the operator
so that section simply adds historic
horse racing to the section that allows
that to happen at a simal cast
facility even though it
would it's different from a horse real
horse racing place where people can get
but it it just seemed There Are Places
all over the country where at least in
the past they have kicked people out
because they had a camera with
that frankly representative I don't
think that's a big part of the bill and
if you wanted to remove it you'd get no
objection from us I I really do View
that as a housekeeping section where HHR
is paramutual selc casting is paramutual
it's just including it in the same
cast
you not really representative nter thank
you Mr chairman the calendar note um
says that this hearing is for Amendment
2358 H but we're hearing about 2444 is
that correct so representative ducet
introduced
2358 and
23444 is
actually um before you just because he
was pointing out a housekeeping change
that we have to make to
2358 uh we were surprised when it came
back from OS I believe that it had a new
number we expected it to be 2358 with a
with a slight yes representative you
said Can clarify it's basically I I
missed three paragraphs where I
mentioned rent so we we're hearing uh
5'8 and this is a friendly Amendment
we're going to bring up after to include
all the components that needed to be
covered yes follow up well I texted the
clerk and I said because I'm confused
and um he said if it's this number is
not in the calendar that we cannot have
a hearing on
it okay told me to tell
yeah I understand the confusion I did
speak with the clerk on actually on this
bill um not this particular Amendment
but the same issue if uh this non-
gerain amendment is
advertised and then I or someone else
comes in and wants to make a tweak or an
amendment to that with within the scope
of the new non- gerain Amendment we can
do do that and um so we're having the
hearing
and our representative duet has
recognized as he's been looking at this
thing that there are a couple of changes
that are within the scope and actually
the word used by the clerk in talking
with me is if there's a
tweak essentially that's what this is
meaning within the scope of the non main
amendment that has now made made the
subject gerain it's okay so we're
discussing this bill um that is tweaked
by that is going to be tweaked if if we
accept
amendment uh yes follow up may I just
show you the text can I come over there
sure
this
were these three paragraphs
important M Mr chairman if I if I may if
I may it seems to me you're having a
hearing on 2358 which was with what was
noticed what I understand is that at
some point there may be during your
executive session a friendly Amendment
off offered to
2358 I believe under the rules that's
permitted that's just my opinion yes yes
and right or wrong I just out of
courtesy mentioned it during my
testimony on 58 so okay so this hearing
is for 2358 only um representative duet
talked
about what what is in this other one but
we are not public hearing this during
exec session we will bring it up thank
you and representative ner does that
answer your question we are this is a
public hearing on 2358 only
okay uh representative
Ellery uh thank you Mr chair just a a
question representative duet um the
moratorium that you have in place I
heard the word permanent and I've heard
it thank you for the question it is a
follow
up with a permanent
moratorium what does that do to a new
charity that wants to get into uh
charitable gaming and maybe
include uh
HHR uh they're been barred from it so
they're at a disadvantage from any other
charitable organization from engaging in
that activity is that not
correct if you pass this that's correct
there would be a limit to the number of
facilities that could have uh historic
horse racing there would not be a limit
to the number of facilities that could
offer table games and poker uh and other
charitable gaming uh activities th those
would continue to be unlimited but yes
it would limit to the current 14 and
potentially the four additional
applicants the ability to have historic
hor racing follow up Mr chair follow up
follow up so you've got
these institutions that are holding
charitable gaming and they've some of
them have HHR anyone who wants to put in
a new gaming facility would then uh a
new venue let's say would then be barred
from putting in
HHR and any
charity who wants to operate or to get
into the gaming activity at one of these
venues would be barred from using the
revenues of the HHR that are there
existing is that correct that's
correct that's the current law we have
we currently have a limit to 14 this
Ames well thank you for for raising the
question representative er um
and I think first I think we're straying
a little bit from this public hearing on
the
amendment this is the discussion we need
to have amongst ourselves but I do want
to say that nothing's permanent in this
legislative world we operate
in and um some of us on this committee
are on the gaming commission which has
at its charge this very subject of of um
competition and uh location of of uh of
uh Charities that can do
HHR and uh we're going to be addressing
that I welcome this amendment because
it it doesn't open the door to to the
world it allows time for the commission
to think about this issue and maybe come
down exactly where this amendment brings
us to but maybe it comes down at a
different place I doubt that it will
come down with a wide open door to to
the anybody but it may set propose
limits and then it's up to the
legislature to adopt that in the
meantime
this this uh new limitation will be in
place if it's adopted by us and by the
legislature until the legislature
decides to change that that's the way I
understand it I totally agree with your
representative I I shouldn't have used
the word permanent obviously we know
that one legislature can't bind another
and you folks may decide next year or
the year after to make some modification
after the commission does its
work thank you thank you representative
Ames I think that was a um a helpful
comment any other any other
questions you have
one I have one for representative set
who should have been testifying I
think I don't okay we're all thank you
thank you oh did somebody have a
question
okay I do have a question after Mr
Newman steps away from the table thank
Newman representative duet I think we'll
bring you up to the uh Podium up here
question
thank you no worries I don't have the
other one but on on
2358 h on and I think it's been there
before but on the new paragraph on p on
line
26 um which apparently rephrases the
language langage that the Lottery
Commission was using to um not permit a
license granted to be transferred or
sold
uh does that help in any way with the
chicanery that's been going on for the
last six eight months 12 months
whatever I I thank you and appreciate
the question uh repres resentative I'm
not sure if Lottery is prepared to and I
don't know whether attorney
uh what does the change in the language
do
then yes represent this is not a change
in the language it's a move Mo move of
okay thank you any other questions for
representative ducet yes I'm not sure
technically if it's for representative
ducet uh or just in general I want to
clarify that there
is nothing in any of our licensing
language that
requires New
Hampshire uh owners potential owners to
be given favor over out of state or out
of country owners is that
correct
represent
duet uh I believe you're correct in that
and also and thank you for the question
and I believe that may be something that
the commission can take up and
um yeah I don't I don't think it negates
any citizen from applying for a business
in New Hampshire it does not give them
favor over say someone from California
or that's not written in the statute
that I'm aware of thank you thank you uh
representative
fellows I actually have a question for
the Lottery
Commission okay um is Lottery
here
okay turn your
mic Valerie King New Hampshire Lottery
and just want to add that Charlie and
John are on their way they had a
different time on the calendar so if
it's something I can't answer they'll be
here
shortly Miss Valerie your last name
again King K
iing representative fellows yes I just
wanted um a little brief description of
the states of the um steps in the
application process you know is did they
fill out a paper and send it in and or
did they they have to go you know get
approved for this and step number one
and then step number two is looking at
something else related to the license
and we're talking about HHR specifically
right
yeah so the first thing they would need
to have is their games of chance uh game
operator license and a facility one and
at the same time they'd also complete an
application for a historic horse racing
what we do is we do have to determine
suitability first that's um something
that we do the leg work and then we send
it to the AG's office for their um
review and approval um if they're found
suitable then the next step we would do
is um we have to go visit the game room
itself and make sure it's ready for
operations we check that the machines
are set up that the cage operations are
ready and that they're ready to go we
don't issue the license until we feel
confident they are ready to go
live follow
up or you also so so do you know where
the the four that or so that are um in
in this Middle Ground they've applied do
you know where they are in the process
if or have they all gone to the AG's
office
or I'm not sure exactly how much I can
disclose but um I can tell you that we
have applications at this
applications so they are they complete
applications did they submit to you an
application that had all of the
information that was required to process
their
application um
I it it
no
representative Aly uh Mr chairman I
believe that we can't ask her to divulge
information she is not allowed to
divulge by the lottery
rules so we'll have to wait for
on on the head of the Lottery Commission
representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman and representative aly's
brought up a good point point if the
investigation I'm sorry I should look at
you if the investigation of the
applicant has been
completed Mr McIntyre the
director uh when I asked him who they
confidential if it's been completed is
it still
confidential that's right have answered
that John or or Charlie can give you
because uh they're attorneys well all
right well maybe we we consider them as
far as I understand we consider them to
be confidential until the license is
is if if the director will be here while
we're still in the hearing that I would
like to have the rest of my question for
him to be addressed at that
time well what we can do we will um
we'll be having a exec session on this
um we can ask that question maybe I
should just give what I'm looking for
and then you can relay it and then the
information come back to us uh when Mr
McIntyre had uh said it was
confidential uh the governing statute is
RSA 287 DD uh games of chance and in
particular in in the above statute 287
D5 it deals with the application process
and
87 287 d8 deals with specific related to
the game operator license which is the
master
license that a gaming operator must have
it which you've I think expressed uh
before they get a historic racing
license and uh this was referenced I
think by representative du
representative du set
okay oh
well shall I wait for Mr McIntyre to
maybe take this question I think that
sense and uh Miss King if you can um
card when you got a chance you can fill
out a pink card
and all right um yes um director
McIntyre thank you for coming good good
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh Charlie McIntyre Lottery
director my apologies I thought this was
at 10:30 not 9:30 so I miscounted it
so may I call we do have we do have a
question for you from representative
shamber thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr McIntyre um you had mentioned in our
last meeting that the names on the list
were confidential
yes and I've done a little bit of
research since then is their names are
still confidential because they are
still being investigated in the
application process or is that process
over right
now so that we can get the list of
names uh before maybe we vote on this so
um the reason the names are confidential
is because there's a suitability review
during the application process we review
the individuals in question and decide
whether they're suitable or not so that
if they're determined unsuitable that
would be confidential as you could
imagine those reviews haven't I don't
believe it finished yet um yeah and
moreover the list actually is I was
informed that it's actually now five
locations not
four well followup Mr chairman follow
up well the reason I bring this up is
that the word confidential only appears
287-291 a which implies that everything
else is subject to 91a
in the ways and means testimony that you
gave you told me you could not release
the names because state law
prohibits you from doing so yeah and I'm
having a hard time just figuring this
out so I
guess certainly when are these names
ever going to be released when they are
approved for a license because if here's
the difficulty represent if I could sort
of phrase the question or phrase the
answer a different way if I tell you
names of the individuals that applied
and then they're not licensed the
confidentiality of that suitability is
no longer valid because in essence you
know know that they weren't suitable for
some reason you can sort of think the
farious thoughts about it so that's the
difficulty in telling you who's applied
because if they then are not licensed
they were then found unsuitable which
would be inferior confidential
fact more the theory in fact
followup so Mr McIntyre then the only
people we're ever going to know who is
applied are those that are suitable and
the rest we never know who is applied at
the end of this process correct would be
that's not that's not as dissimilar from
think representative fellows yes so so
my questions are kind of related to this
application process it in the step the
um what we're looking at for an
amendment it
says that there's an exclusion for for
um
applicants entities that applied for a
license so my question is I don't know
how extensive the application is but I'm
wondering if somebody could have just
kind of like put in their name as a
placeholder as opposed to filling out
the complete application and if it's an
extensive application then that there
to good morning um drn Cony Chief
compliance officer for the New Hampshire
lottery um the application itself is not
extensive however there are several um
requirements operational requirements uh
those types of documents
uh such as internal control surveillance
plans um game rules those types of
things that need to be completed um in
association with the application um so
I'm as you know we just we just walked
in here I think if um you can have
submitted an
application um and it would not be
complete until all of those subsequent
documents would be um would be both
submitted and and then reviewed viewed
um and that typically happens closer to
um the uh time of
operation I don't know if that answered
your
question representative Aly
thank I didn't catch your name sir I'm
sorry it's John coni it's um Co n f r TI
and the chief compliance officer for the
uh representative
ready I would like to ask on in the
document that we are looking at and the
next one that's coming up uh it says
applied for game operator employer
license between January 1 23 and October
1823 that's 3 weeks ago um we're only
now learning that there's a fifth
one did they apply before the fif 18th
so representative Aly um I was informed
by staff this week that there had been
an application that had been submitted
in July that uh neither director
McIntyre or I were aware of uh because
it had not um progressed very
uh far beyond the application stage um
but we just learned about that literally
this
follow I well given that we were um made
aware of that uh this week I did uh
inquire of our staff as to whether there
were any other pending applications or
things that could be pending um and that
was the only one that I was made aware
of thank thank you anything else yes
represent elberger thank you Mr chairman
I just want to clarify that there is no
opportunity thank you uh there's no
opportunity for any kind of public input
applications yeah that that is correct
there there is a um uh excuse me sorry I
didn't see where the question came from
um there is an a a review process that
involves the Lottery Commission and the
Attorney General's office but um there
is not a public input uh component with
respect to the gaming license there may
be with respect to any of the local
approvals that they may need to open an
establishment um but as far as our
licensing process there isn't a public
input component of that follow up
followup thank you um
so being a suspicious type
if there is somebody who may have had
experience that's not public or publicly
known with a uh license someone who is a
license applicant and that information
might be Germaine to the decision as to
whether to support the license
application or not there's no way for
that person who might know something
that would be useful to get that
information to you
um they would not necessarily be aware
that um there would be an application
pending we do try to um on our own
initiative uh do as much investigation
and obviously the Department of Justice
does as well um to um obtain as much
information as we possibly can on a
prospective applicant but you're correct
that um somebody would not necessarily
know and know to come to us um based on
Public Information thank you and and I
would think that that would be a
potential issue for all sorts of avenues
where we depend on uh agencies to do the
investigation representative PL just
point out to me the obvious if there
were a public input process would not NE
confidentiality well
yes certainly the
process has to go for the town before
they finalize their licensed with us
they have to get approvals because we
have to know what it looks like what the
buildout is the surveillance cameras is
compliance officer suggested so
um
any any other uh questions comments I
do yes represent Southworth thank you
for taking my question I just want to
double check um there's no problem with
eliminating the annual financial
statement it's redundant or there some
reason you don't need it
anymore um we we looked at that and
based on other uh requirements that we
have in the rules and uh both on the
historic course racing side and the
auditing rules that we have currently um
that that was really redundant
information at this point great thank
you uh yes representative ner thank you
Mr chairman um are we allowed to know
the locations of the
establishments we no
we haven't sort of notified folks
confidential thank you yes
representative Lee
Lee thank you it seems that the
fundamental question is what is
confidential it seems like this I'm not
an attorney um I'm an average person
representing average people and an
average person reading this um law it
sounds like the protected inform
information is the outcomes of the
criminal check and the background check
I I don't understand that an applicant
would have a right to apply in secrecy
and I'm not sure
why they wouldn't want people to know
that they're applying so it sounds a
little bit like there's been some creep
in the interpretation of the law I'm not
sure why applicants deserve secrecy in
this it it seems seems like we're
talking about something
that's it doesn't seem like you would
need to maintain
your fact that you're applying as
confidential or the fact where this
might take place as confidential so I
guess my question
is how did you arrive at that
interpretation of the state law was that
your own was that the AG's
interpretation thank
you well one of the difficulties in
maintaining conf confidential
information is that once you've released
it you no longer get to bring it back
you understand my point is if I released
the list and then I was found to be in
violation of that I violated the law
sought we haven't sought opinion to the
attorney general in this in this regard
specifically no only because it's come
up only in this
context it it really so for years
nobody's ever asked what the list looked
like and who was applied the only reason
is in this context of the moratorium and
these d in question but so let me re may
I restate my question so my question
is what do you understand to be
confidential it sounds to me like the
state law is protecting information the
information that's protected is the
results of the background check and
results of a criminal
check it doesn't sound like the list
itself or the identity of an applicant
itself is protected did it is that your
interpretation of the law and how did
you arrive at your interpretation of the
law was it your own the the answer is
yes it's our interpretation of the law
I'm happy to review this with the
Attorney General's office subsequent to
this but certainly our interpretation
only because the state usually balances
the protection of confidential
information more than it does the
release of it but that's just our
understanding we're happy to review this
with the AG but question's not about
releasing or not releasing just to be
protected
yes representative ery this is addressed
to representative lefley having forly
held a private investigator's license
from the
state and you can't find out who is or
is not a licensed private investigator
unless it directly uh involves you
that's a privacy restriction on that
particular license remember a license is
a grant to do something that is
otherwise
illegal there are several other licenses
that are granted by the state that are
confidential in order to protect both
the ly particularly in my case from
malicious activity
uh and to protect the public in general
so that they don't have a large number
of oh you do do this you do that granted
most private investigators want to
advertise but they'll advertise a
business address rather than a personal
address and on a private investigator's
license they need to give the personal
address uh just that that type of
activity so I understand where they're
coming from in the lottery and I I'm
hoping that you can see how you can
translate that over to the lottery
activity there is a question and the uh
regarding whether or not the public
should have input
as to the uh lenses uh suitability for
the project and I'm glad that we're
going to check that out with the
attorney general and follow up Mr chair
follow up and
uh Mr McIntyre
if somebody wants to put in a facility
they still have to uh go to a public
Hearing in the town in which the
facility wishes to behave and there's
ample time at that point for the the
public in general to make a uh a
protestation of one type or another is
that correct um actually to follow up on
that thank you for the question
representative um there's even more
input than that each city or town is
certainly free to Zone as it sees fit to
where the activity would best be suited
for the town a number of jurisdictions
have zoned in this activity to certain
areas within the town so not only do
they have their rights during the
hearing process for permitting and
Zoning that the town itself has a right
to vote saying it belongs in Industry a
or business whatever a number of towns
have done that so um there's more than
that that that type of input thank you
Mr chair thank you representative Aly
thank you isn't it true that the town
has almost no rights of control over
that that casino and that on the zoning
has to be done before the IDE a that a
casino might be interested in your town
shows up because at that point they have
in I I would say yes representative Aly
they have obviously anyone who applies
for a um a building permit or other um
uh permit or application through the
town has the same rights um that any
other business would have um I think to
director McIntyre's point point that um
the the town or city where this would be
going in would have oversight over over
the casino only to the extent um that
they would have oversight over any other
business in that's applying for a
similar license so with respect to the
gaming portion of it they would only
have that sort of right um to restrict
uh through zoning which they many have
done um and are continuing to do as
gaming is now now expanded and and the
uh potential for uh a gaming
establishment to come into a
municipality is is growing um so a
number of the municipalities are
addressing that um before um an
forward okay uh representative elberger
thank you Mr
chairman can a community simply say we
we're not going to allow gaming here no
if you've approved a
license
sort of prior to operation we would seek
the town's approval the town would the
operator itself would seek the town's
approval to begin operation um I don't
want to get too into this because there
are certain communities that are
opposing facilities currently and I
don't want to speak to it because I
don't you know there may be litigation
but certainly the town has its rights
regarding zoning and permitting to
approve the activity or
not as relates to zoning of permitting
they're silent on the issue of gaming
it's a difficult question right just
follow up follow up not not a question
but more a statement so a community
doesn't have the ability to say no and
before the process has gotten very far
down the
road nobody knows who's applying for a
where well with respect to again with
respect to the town or city it the the
process is the same as it would be for a
restaurant or a bar um so they would
have to initiate those processes and um
director McIntyre is a lot smarter than
I am I am not an expert on local zoning
uh laws I'm barely uh you know
conversing on the things I'm supposed to
be conversing on so I can't um I can't
tell you what that process looks like
for a town or city um but certainly they
would have the same insight into that
business activity that they would with
respect to every other business activity
but with respect to our licensing you
are correct they would not have insight
into
that okay seeing no more questions
we'll thank you very
much is there anyone else who hasn't uh
testify okay seeing none we'll end this
public
hearing
all right the time being uh
10:28 uh we will start the work session
on HB 1221 relative to worldwide
combined reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax
does anyone have any comments uh yes
representative spillsbury thank you Mr
chairman um I had the uh duty of
chairing the commission on combined
worldwide reporting that was authorized
by the legislature in
2022 under
hb12 and uh everyone's received the
report you was an extensive report 16
page uh Minority Report there were seven
U Commissioners and six um adopted that
report uh there was a qualifying
statement um from the association the
Society of CPAs and uh the Dr that they
were neutral on the recommendation but
endorsed the report there's a Minority
Report from representative
shamberg uh minutes
and uh a bibliography all of which is
posted on the general Court's uh website
on a page dedicated to the commission
and accessible with links and citations
and so on so it's a lot to have read I I
hope most of you have had a chance to
read it um I'm not going to uh get into
reciting the report because it's very
involved very complicated subject and uh
I would say if you haven't read it yet
the first first eight pages are a very
uh neutral measured recitation of uh all
of the positions and opinions that the
commission
heard uh and you can jump to the
findings if you don't want to Wade
through that detail the findings
analysis and recommendation can be read
in several pages so
succinctly the commission recommends
that New Hampshire does not Implement
combined worldwide report
reporting and that it rests with the
wat's edge limitation currently in
statute therefore the commission
recommends that uh
hb11 is not um moved
forward and the commission took uh makes
a second recommendation that there is no
need for further study at this time but
there are conditions that uh maybe worth
monitoring and could change change the
environment in coming years particularly
if the federal government um takes a
different stance So currently our law
aligns with the Internal Revenue
code currently the bottom line on a
business's federal tax return is the
point of departure for a New Hampshire
uh return and if HB 1221 was to be
adopted it would completely delink link
us from the federal IRC it would require
multinational businesses to prepare an
entirely different uh sort of tax return
and we would lose all of the benefits of
um piggybacking off of the federal code
we would also lose all of the positive
impact of the massive audit work done by
the Internal Revenue Service that the
New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration
is not equipped to do so I'll leave it
there uh and glad to answer any
questions representative PL yes
representative spillsbury are there any
other states using worldwide
reporting no um the answer is no there
were about I think it was 11 states that
adopted combined worldwide reporting in
the late 70s and early 80s at new
Hampshire was one of those in
1981 and that regime although on the
books was never applied to foreign-based
multinationals creating an
extraordinarily discriminatory system
where the US multinationals were
burdened in a way that the foreign
multinationals were not and as a result
of that as well as a policy review and
pressure from the federal government in
regards to international relations uh
state of New apire repealed combined
worldwide reporting in
1986 and by about that time all of the
states that had enacted it also repealed
it so we've now been about 40 years
nearly with no State um implementing
this
regime I'll just ask um how did the vote
from the commission go what was the vote
one
question yes question do um
representative
a I guess this is in part an
observation um I believe it's true that
there are several states that has H have
an
option that uh
Corporation a taxpayer can uh Avail
themselves of which is is to use
worldwide combined reporting instead of
the other system that that State uh
defaults to and uh so California for
example I believe Massachusetts I could
be wrong on that and a few others um
have that option and in fact many
corporations or some corporations I
don't have detail are using it uh so in
response to to the question about use of
worldwide combin reporting it is being
used in some places so that that's a
very worthwhile clarification thank you
for it there is no state that mandates
corre there are a handful of states or
less that allow an
option interestingly the state of Maine
has just gone through a study and um
issued a report in August that
specifically reviewed the
proposal of going to the option and they
decided against
it and they their their evaluation was
that there was no benefit to the state
of offering the option because it simply
created a situation where a corporation
would elect whichever method was more
itself yes representative uh elberger
thank you Mr chairman I can't picture
any corporation that wouldn't choose to
take the option that was most
financially beneficial to them I mean
all of us would do that in our own
private lives uh I am concerned about
the idea
that in a state where we believe that
people should have the ability
to should have equal options
to run their lives run their businesses
that this commission is coming out and
saying that we are more than willing to
allow foreign-based companies to have an
advantage over our own New Hampshire
based companies it it's it's a it kind
of boggles the mind that we are not
saying that our local companies don't
have at least the same uh opportunities
for tax uh advantages or disadvantages
as those that are based in other
countries thank
you repres representative spillsbury um
yes so interesting observations the
representative Elber I think there's two
different points you're making that I'd
like to respond
to first I I think it is worth
noting that in a state where if if we
were to allow the
option there are as representative Ames
pointed out multinationals that elect
worldwide combined
reporting and that's a very interesting
thing to note because it tells you that
the
assumption that mandating worldwide
combined reporting will necessarily be
beneficial to the state IE will
necessarily raise more taxes is faulty
the way worldwide combined reporting
works in the briefest possible way is a
corporation is required to expand the
tax base they report to include all
foreign operations subsidiaries of
American based
multinationals Affiliates Upstream
Downstream and parent of foreign uh
corporations but when you've expanded
the base that doesn't mean you're going
to get more in taxes it just means that
the
equation where you take the portion
alloc allocable to New
Hampshire over the overall
activity is going to have a larger
denominator and a vastly watered down
numerator so whether you're going to end
up having more tax revenue is going to
depend on whether that particular
corporation
had a higher rate of
profit with their activities inside the
United States or whether they had a
higher rate of profit with their
activities
elsewhere and there will be winners and
losers it will be completely
unpredictable a corporation that may pay
more taxes this year may pay less taxes
another year so it's a
clue that where an election is
allowed there are multin corporations
that elect worldwide combined reporting
and that's because it's just as likely
to be a tax advantage to them and a
revenue disadvantage to the state so it
is it's just a completely faulty
premise that expanding the base will
result in Greater tax revenue that this
the second
part of what you're talking about is the
disadvantage
there are all kinds of tax rules that we
deploy depreciation allowances and so on
uh that you can qualify for if you
invest you don't qualify if you don't
invest it's not a it's not a
discriminatory system that some people
Avail themselves of depreciation
allowances and others aren't in that
situation this is very similar it's not
discriminatory first of all the law
treats a United states-based
multinational exactly the same way it
treats a foreign-based
multinational so any Corporation dealing
in multinational activities is treated
exactly alike under the
law the argument I think you may be
zeroing in on is whether there's a
perceived disadvantage to a
purely domestic
Corporation maybe the ultimate example
would be a business that only does
businesses in the state of New Hampshire
and doesn't even do business in another
state but that's a that's a business
that 5 years from now could grow and
start doing business in other states
that's a business that could start doing
business in Europe tomorrow so
businesses aren't static businesses
choose how broadly um they want to
compete and they're not static so I I I
think it's also a faulty premise that
there is a discriminatory aspect of the
law there are different outcomes there
differential circumstances but the law
is
even-handed thank you representative
Aly thank you I have a little bit of
problem with your
description of what
happened in the
80s
because on
we on during the on coid worst of the
coid pandemic on we had a uh Zoom
meeting for several hours with the
proponents of worldwide combined
reporting and one of them was the
successor of the man that first
developed combined reporting
for
multi-state
work on they did that in California
because um the film industry was making
a lot of uh was avoiding a lot of taxes
by um filming one copy of their films
and sending them for
$5 to um another state which didn't have
a tax on the film industry and um where
they were multiplied and sent all over
the country um tax fre um
and
on he this gentleman
was I think almost 90 he may be dead now
but on he pointed out that uh they
started doing this across they they set
up this s situation in
California uh for the other states and
then they started later on to think
about doing it
internationally and they did on
Implement on worldwide combined
reporting
internationally for at least some period
he mentioned that uh the greatest
problem that they'd had in terms of the
work for their on tax agency was that
they'd had to send one person to
Japan to uh audit
something
and uh but that in general all of these
companies overseas were used to working
in English and so they were able to do
most most of it by probably in those
days air
mail so so
um there was uh there were apparently a
number of states also that were
implementing this with not as an option
but as a requirement but it may not have
gotten too far before Margaret Thatcher
got uh Ronald Reagan to lean on all of
the states that were doing it and tell
them not to do it
anymore so so just just to clarify the
um it's correct that when New Hampshire
first instituted the BPT in
1970 we used a separate filing mechanism
just like the IRS
does and it's also true that we
enacted worldwide combined reporting in
1981 it's not accurate that we ever
implemented it so and and and so I did I
did indicate before there were I believe
11 states that also enacted it and all
repealed it none of them still has it so
I don't think it was
misstated representative PL yes another
question for representative spillsbury
there are certain States you say who
will give a choice of worldwide
reporting of Water's
Edge and as a result of that the
businesses will choose one or the other
depending on what's favorable to that
business if that's true if we were to
mandate
here uh we we it's a crapshoot whether
revenues would go up or down isn't it
because a business could be paying more
under the water's edge than they would
have worldwide reporting is that correct
that is correct it's it's
unable which taxpayers would see their
tax liability increase and which ones
decrease representative
Ames yeah this
uh experience that's uh clearly happened
in states where the election the option
is
available
um should uh be an experience that would
be help help all of
us understand um the re realities of
worldwide combined reporting not
mandated it but some
corporations large small I don't know
um are choosing to put
forward um their calculation of their
tax liability using this accounting
method and um those
States these tax departments in those
states have had to respond to that
either accepted or uh audit it or U
whatever and that experience I would
think would be very
interesting um and
including um any information that's
available about uh which way these
corporations go and how that relates to
revenue the the must be information out
there that would be helpful I'm my
question is whether this commission
looked at all to those States for
information on uh that experience I I
think that's a very constructive
question and the the answer is we took
cognizance of them but we did not do
research into what their experience is
and so the commission um has stated
nothing to that point however um we we
did specifically consider the recent
main
study and the one I referred to before
which uh came out in August and that is
in our record and accessible through the
commission's web page and might be worth
reading so they did evaluate
specifically that question and and just
I think you said it before but the
conclusion of that was what so the
conclusion of the state of Maine was to
not um to not adopt the options so they
they continue to be a Water's Edge State
like we are uh I'm going to give you a
different example there are a number of
states in the last half dozen years that
have considered and declined to go
forward Indiana in 2017 issued a very
extensive report in which they said that
they could imagine there would be a
moderate uh uptick in Revenue in the
first couple of years that would resolve
towards a net zero um and that it just
wasn't worth
doing there uh there was a proposal in
inota this past year that was adopted in
the uh passed in the Minnesota house and
died in the Senate did not get
enacted um also very interesting is that
Rhode Island within the past year has
concluded a study with about a 90 page
report very detailed it's a different
circumstance but it tells us a
lot Rhode Island uses separate
filing they've never adopted combined
filing either on the water's edge limit
or
worldwide so they studied the question
whether they should move to combined
reporting and they concluded that they
wanted to stay separate reporting in in
line with the IRS so I won't
characterize their study but 90 pages in
a lot of detail and they weren't even
edge thank you we're willing to go to
Water's Edge Rhode Island decided to
leave their law as it is now which is
separate filing rather than
leapley thank you um so I have two items
um my first question is about the makeup
of the commission um it seems like it
was very small and it seems like it
wasn't um entirely representative of
people who might have an interest in
this item can you talk a little bit
commission so the commission of course
was dictated by hb12 and acted in 2022
and it described 12
members
and seven of those appointments were
filled five were never appointed
despite repeated requests initially by
representative abrami when he was first
seated as chair and then further renewed
by me several times during this summer
so both of us uh through the house clerk
Paul Smith made an effort to try and Jog
the other uh listed interests so that
for
example the
um Department of uh uh economics and
development is that what it's called DEA
Taylor caswell's department had a member
he left the department and they did not
um fill that vacancy the Attorney
General did not make an appointment and
there were a couple of other um Bia
positions two of them that were never
filled um but I will I will tell you
representative leapley that we went out
of our way
to make sure that we heard from
everybody who indicated an interest in
uh in in speaking before
us we also went out of our way to
structure the hearing so that the New
Hampshire based interests were up first
and had an opportunity to frame the
issue and uh I referred to that in the
commission's report as New Hampshire
Centric we wanted to put them up up on
the platform and uh let their opinion be
centered first so we certainly did try
uh to hear and and and nobody who
indicated an interest in in presenting
to us was turned
away I have a followup followup thank
you uh I certainly appreciate the
commission's work I certainly appreciate
your work um it was very serious and I
know time consuming so thank thank you
for that um I want to talk about framing
the issue because I feel like that's
really key here um we've addressed the
Assumption um it seems that what was
framed here is the assumption that
um this would necessarily raise more
taxes and that that assumption um was
found to be false I don't think that was
the central
Focus I think it's an important focus of
this commission but I think an equally
important focus of the commission is tax
Justice and
fairness and so I think it's it might be
slightly misleading
to frame this as you want to raise more
taxes this doesn't do that and therefore
we should not pass it um I think a
question that's that's equally important
is the fairness question and we don't
know doesn't equal it won't and I feel
like almost everything we do in this
committee is often there's a lot that we
don't know about how changing taxes will
affect revenues so I think that that's
not particularly different or special in
this case um there were some things that
were raised that I actually read as
opposite at of the commission for
example um there was a lobbyist that
shared the information that 14% there
was a 14% growth in international thanks
to International or foreign
multinationals in the state there was a
14 um% increase in employment by those
firms whereas the rest of the economy
only grew 7% and therefore this is a
very important base um of taxpayers that
we should treat carefully and my take
away from that is if they're growing
their employment by
14% everybody else is Growing Up by
7% I want to make extra sure that
they're paying their fair share of taxes
so that we can develop a Workforce if
they're drawing on our Workforce
disproportionately it makes sense that
they pay their fair share of taxes right
so yes it's a benefit it's wonderful
that they're generating employment it
costs the state money to educate people
so I I don't necessarily have the same
takeaway um on some of these issues
another point that was made in the
commission study um by someone who
presented was that New
Hampshire we're actually doing a great
job
of corporate taxation because we have
the biggest percentage um of our income
is coming from taxing corporations so
we're doing great so we shouldn't tax
them any further um and my takeaway from
from that point was that again if this
is the biggest part of our taxation we
need to be extra sure that we're taxing
corporations fairly because we have a
greater
interest greater than any other state in
the outcome of that taxation so again I
I I don't think that that's a oh we
better take our hands off I think we
better be extra careful that we're
taxing
fairly
um a third point is that we're talking
about picking winners or losers and we
don't want to pick winners or
losers the it's ironic in the Deep sense
of irony um because this bill was
brought forward because the argument is
that the state is picking winners and
losers currently and we would like to
stop doing that and I think the argument
that the law is not discriminatory that
we treat all multinationals the same is
missing the
point we're not talking about
multinationals not being treated equally
we're talking about people who just
exist in New Hampshire who don't exist
multinationally who are not taking
advantage of these very expensive
sophisticated accounting techniques to
avoid taxation they're paying taxation
that that we should proceed carefully
and in you know deciding that we're
we're treating all of them the same my
final point is the commission report um
seemed to claim that there was no proof
that there is tax avoidance going on
whereas the
oecd which I think is a pretty credible
um
International body of over 140 qu uh
countries says that there are billions
and billions and billions of dollars
that are not being taxed so I think this
is a real problem um it's a real problem
that New Hampshire is interested in more
interested in than others States so I
don't want to to be dismissive of this
very difficult question I think the
commission did a great job um I think
this is worthy of further consideration
and I think it is worthy of being
discussed by our legislature because we
have a bigger interest in this than any
other state in the country thank you
thank you
um I saw uh representative um PL first
thank you thank you Mr chair um repres
spillsbury you stated that you gave New
Hampshire Centric business's first
opportunity but at the Apple did you
find any support for New Hampshire from
New Hampshire businesses for worldwide
reporting yes there there are definitely
Advocates and we had a representative of
a Business Association um with two other
uh people with him and they made a
passionate case in favor of worldwide
combined reporting so yes we did hear
that but that doesn't mean that it was a
fact-based case or that it was a
quantifiable case it was a theoretical
case if if yes thank you m Mr chair uh
would you not expect if New Hampshire
businesses thought that worldwide
reporting would raise taxes for people
out out side uh New
Hampshire that that they'd be supported
as a competitive
Advantage because they won't pay it but
others
will let me make sure I understood what
you asked did you you just asked if I
thought more Revenue could be derived
from foreign multinationals would
not New Hampshire businesses be urging
that we move in that direction is that
what you asked there's a competitive
Advantage because they screwing the
other
guys well perhaps I I I will just say I
was surprised that there wasn't more
uptake um and uh more businesses that
came forward and wanted to uh give us
some at least anecdotes um I'd like to
give credit to representative leapley
who attended two of our very long
sessions including the all day of
hearings um she's obviously deeply
interested so if I could take another
couple of minutes just to address
distilling the various points you've
made you're concerned with
fairness and I want to be very
clear the
commission did not state that there is
no
problem the commission went out of its
way to explicitly
acknowledge that the
opportunity and the
potential for misusing transfer uh
pricing uh techniques allowable
justifiable techniques that may be used
specifically to shift profit to a lower
tax jurisdiction overseas that
opportunity there's no question it
exists there is no question that it's
used the
problem is that the problem is several
the problem is number one it's not
quantifiable and any efforts to quantify
it can be very effectively um
rebutted second it's not clear how
extensive it is or whether it represents
a truly material problem for the state
in terms of our goal
of generating
Revenue number three it is drastic ially
over
Brad it basically takes a concern that
certain taxpayers are using transfer
pricing let's say to shift profits on
the basis of licenses or royalties or
you know other um payments for
intellectual property and
intangibles um and it says okay so
here's the solution we're going to
require you and and everybody you're
related
to to declare all of your worldwide
activity and your profits in every
country I used to work for a
multinational that was in 76
countries so that Corporation would have
to file its uh its activities it's uh
basically translate its tax returns from
foreign currencies and foreign languages
and foreign General accepted accounting
practices and it
is
drastically
underestimated what kind of a burden
this is going to place on the taxpayers
it is dras drastically underestimated
and not understood what kind of a
challenge this would place on the
Dr so I think that if this was perceived
as
being the right solution to the
perception that there
is a fairness
problem we would create far more
problems than we
solve and you've got to really ask
yourself why is it after decades and
Decades of controversy that the US
Congress has never tried to implement
something like this if the United States
government doesn't think it's worth
going after in this p in this fashion
then how in the world is New Hampshire
going to effectively move in that
direction on its own and what do we give
up when we dink from the IRS and from
from the uh from the code
um I I
[Music]
just the Contours of this proposed
solution are not even slightly in
alignment with the description of the
problem even if you accept the problem
as
genuine
thank
you uh representative ery uh thank you
Mr
chair um having been on the commission
and attended the uh at least this year's
uh sessions of it a couple of uh things
came to mind the question regarding
fairness treatment of Taxation was
raised
repeatedly and if I'm not mistaken uh
one of the comments was that the same
tax code applies to every person in the
state
currently there is a difference in
magnitude of scale on some of the
corporations to be sure and that's going
to happen regardless of what kind of
system is put in place magnitud
scale there was also a discussion as to
whether or not the ver what the tax
Foundation rates New Hampshire I think
is number six uh Rich States poor states
has it uh New Hampshire in the top 20 uh
for the business environments uh that
question was also raised as to whether
or not it would have a adverse effect
upon businesses particularly large
businesses in the state of New Hampshire
that rely on high-tech New Hampshire has
become a high-tech environment um we've
got some stuff in this uh uh immediate
area that uh really causes people to
take pause uh as to where they're going
because of its proximity to Boston
because of the tax environment that
exists for the
corporations so if the fairness is do
are we going to trade
off employing people in the state
increasing Revenue uh from the BET BPT
which is applied equally to every single
business I believe um Mr Kean was there
and made that uh uh comment to that
effect then we have the question about
uh what what is it um um price transfer
which is take the technical term for
moving from place to place monies of
course that takes place most businesses
in New Hampshire do it all the time
large or small and I believe the report
that was created said that it does take
place but as to the degree whether or
not this was hiding profits from
taxation or merely uh taking profits
from one business here and giving it to
another business over there not for the
purpose of hiding
profits like a greedy Rich business
would do but to help another division of
the same company be more successful hire
people and produce a product a good or
something or services that people want
so I I that was pretty clear stated if
I'm not mistaken in our
um um report is that
correct well yes and I think those are
extremely valid points for those who've
had a chance to read the report yes
you'll see that that's very clearly
stated so for those who haven't had a
chance to read the report I'd like to
just say
categorically transfer pricing is
legitimate it's necessary it's actually
required so so the question isn't
whether transfer pricing is inherently
bad the question is whether transfer
pricing is used by certain people to
minimize or reduce
tax um I give you an
analogy if a parent owns a patent on a
recipe they're going to charge their
subsidiaries for the use of the recipe
right a parallel um instead of thinking
in terms of complicated multinational
businesses think of a franchise
operation if a franchisor has franchises
around the country and some franchisee
has a dozen Subways uh that franchis
under
contract agrees to pay for the
recipes the brand name the marketing
program and so on so inherently you're
going to to have
subsidiaries making payments to a parent
for the use of those intellectual
property and other intangible assets
that the parent owns that's what
bad representative
Aly thank you I'm kind of appalled and
I'm sorry I was uh too sick during a
large part of of the work that you were
doing to
and then too busy to be able to show up
and um there there is
substantial data on tax Havens around
the world that is something that is not
something that is uh just
transferring profits for for the
purposes of this SU ESS of the business
except to reduce their taxes there are a
large number of corporations that have
been shown to pay almost nothing to the
maintenance of our federal government
because they are using a lot of these
mechanisms um and there are several
there were several studies done
on on before we started getting into
this
business uh that
showed on quantitatively that there
would be an increase in New Hampshire
tax revenue if um if we could figure out
how to do this and there are other
reasons
why we may need to do a bunch more work
on how how to to get it done but to
abandon the entire principle because all
of this tax evasion is going on
internationally on is seems to me to be
um
you yes represent yeah one thing I'd
like to promise all of my colleagues on
the ways and mean committee is that the
commission did not proceed in an
ideological
way uh there was no preconceived
conclusions it was an extraordinarily
comprehensive and balanced review and
you'll see that when you read the
commission's
report the I think most of your
observations are
accurate and and so in no way did the
Commission in its report try to pretend
that this doesn't happen but it's an
international problem it's a problem
that the IRS deals with it's a problem
that Congress has considered from time
to time it's a problem that's been
addressed in a host of different ways
through our work with the organization
of economic cooperation and development
oecd the pillar one and pillar
two there were major aspects of the 2017
tax cuts and jobs act that focused on
this problem because it is real right um
and so the uh the guilty we tax guilty
at 50% we also new hire also taxes All
Foreign uh
dividends when repatriated to the United
States so there are a host of different
methods and ways of trying to address
the problem and mitigate the problem I
don't think anybody has devised a
solution
they haven't devised a solution on the
international level or the national
level and I think it's a bit delusional
to think we're going to suddenly do
something here that's going to create a
solution in New Hampshire I without
getting into the weeds I would also just
suggest to
you even if you think that worldwide
combined reporting is the right thing to
do hb1 121 doesn't do it if you read
hb21 it
80% is Preparatory language in history
debatable the actual active language of
the bill is a list of six Provisions
that would be repealed so as to
eliminate the waterers Edge
limitation and then there are two
Provisions in law where a sentence or a
portion of a sentence is
added in our
hearings and in our commission
discussion the dr's representatives made
it very clear that this bill would be
inadequate to do what it even purports
to do it's completely lacking in a
mechanism it's completely lacking in
definitions it gives the Dr No guidance
whatsoever in
fact if you go
to page three of the
bill it essentially rests on a single
sentence that's been added at lines 24
and 25 this provision shall authorize
the application of worldwide combined
reporting that is not
legislating and that doesn't actually
give the Dr anything that they can go
work with so you know maybe another bill
in another legislature for some somebody
who still thinks this is the path to
take thank you now I just I'll recognize
representative leapley in a second here
but let me first say that any more
comments let's try to keep them to new
new thoughts because we are um the time
being uh almost 11:20 and we have a lot
of work to do let's try to keep it to
please thank you um so I have a couple
um thoughts first of all this being the
committee on ways and means I think it
is our job to be extremely
curious about
Taxation and to learn as much as we can
about who we tax in the state how we tax
in the state how taxes are avoided by
taxpayers in the state um and and
avoidance just to be clear is
legal um so I'm not casting
aspersions
um so one I think it's our job to ask
these questions and to be curious and to
try to understand these issues better
um it's very hard as an everyday person
to
understand what is happening here a lot
of the discussion of the commission um
when it got into details would for
example be about guilty what is guilty
we tax guilty and so therefore we're tax
we're we're capturing this Federal money
and an everyday person is like what's
guilty oh we're taxing it okay so we're
all
set it's so what I'm getting at here is
that it's very easy for this to go into
such technical langu language that the
actual questions being asked aren't
answered um guilty is taxed at a 10%
rate between 10 and 133% in the state of
New Hampshire I think that an everyday
coffee shop you know maybe Revel Stoke
downtown would love to pay 10% so if
we're saying something kind of tossing
it off that oh we tax guilty so we all
set like let's acknowledge that that is
not the corporate tax rate that is
normally
taxed the other thing I want to bring up
is yes um the oecd is tackling this yes
pillar one and two are perhaps Solutions
um again I'm just an average person but
my understanding right now is that while
the US um has signed on to Beeps we are
not participating in pillar one and
pillar too and if as a New Hampshire
taxpayer I think it's important that we
have this discussion because if our
federal government is not going to sign
on to pillar one and two and we don't
even understand what that means one of
the things it could mean is that the
other 140 countries are starting to get
their taxes back from these
multinationals right so you know big
company a France is going to get their
20% you know Micronesia is going to get
their 20% but if we don't start paying
attention to what is going on
internationally we're not going to get
our share so I think it is in the
interest of New Hampshire to talk about
these very complicated unsexy
issues um maybe even talk about them on
the floor of the legislature so that
they can be more widely understood and
so that we send a message to the federal
government that the choices that they
make affect New Hampshire because as it
stands now we are dependent on what is
happening at the federal level so if
they're not opting in to International
tax treaties that
capture actual the real revenues made
and just to be clear when we're talking
about you
know this being very difficult for
companies to file taxes that
show the actual revenues
made on the international level we're
talking about companies that have
revenues higher than
750 billion no sorry million dollars a
year so if we're going to talk about oh
taxes are really complicated and hard
these tax avoidance procedures are
really complicated and hard and that's
why our local New Hampshire businesses
while you're right technically legally
can use these same tax avoidance
structures they're really expensive and
if you make a billion dollars a year it
might be interesting to you to execute
that but if you're just a mom and pop
it's not and I'm thinking about my own
kids they would like to grow up and
build their own businesses right
so they might want to do they might want
to have a rubel Stoke more than they
want to go work for $17 an hour at
Starbucks so when we're talking about
these issues we're talking about the
future of our kids and their ability to
compete as business owners really
matters so I hope that the Curiosity
that this bill and that this commission
has raised won't end with this
commission or today's discussion
but will increase because this is really
impacting Us in New Hampshire and our
kids in New Hampshire I know it seems
very far away and very International and
very high level but this kind of stuff
is impacting our retailers ability to
stay in business every day so I hope
that it will
stay in our Consciousness thank you
thank
okay I'm going to close the work session
on
hp11 and we'll now open the work session
192 representative Alid you might have a
point to make yeah this one is easy I
think on this bill was written with the
assumption that the indd tax exists the
IND tax will cease to exist on the
31st uh of December of this year on this
bill would come to
the oh uh
1124 no the the
on
it it is
repealed as of the end of this
year I believe HB I believe hb2 has it
repealed by the end of next year uh by
the end of
24 yeah 2% there was a difference
between the bill so the bill that that I
sponsored um had it ending at the end of
this year but H when it got into hb2 it
actually ends at the end of 24 could we
ask on Mr Wong
to
because well does that distinction
affect your comment your
point well Mr Wong is at the podium so
we'll um please introduce yourself and
uh good morning ke Mong from the
Department of Revenue I believe uh if
memory serves me that the repeal is uh
effective for tax bill periods ending uh
beginning after December
3125 yeah for tax periods ending a
beginning yeah but when I tried to
reference in a new bill to reference RSA
exist
1124 well I
I don't know that that's that was the
bill as introduced but in
hb2 uh it ends 1231 tax periods ending
3124 yeah so but that doesn't affect
your point does it uh it doesn't affect
my point in the sense that having been
told that I could not on act on a a a
law which is
repealed on that on I decided to get
more ambitious about this and uh I have
uh written with help from Dr I have
written a total rewrite of the century
old
law and um set it up in a new
chapter that will be her in
January which does do the same things of
uh increasing the exemptions tripling
the exemptions because they haven't been
changed since before my time here which
more than 30 years I'm not sure how far
back it goes um and
um and that bill will be coming
forward and this bill and
as I was told on could not happen
because it is based on something that is
being repealed so um that is already
repealed for a future date and you're
making it a lot more complicated than I
thought it was but um so I would be
willing when we get to the voting
session to move itl on this one partly
also because the
the existing law which dies either the
end of this year the end of next year um
is
um was written in the beginning of the
20th century and has been accreted onto
in ways that make it very very difficult
for anybody who's not a tax expert at
indd law to know what they're doing
so
um so that is um what I'm planning on
comments seeing none I will end the work
192 we'll now open the work session on
HB
569 and uh representative Ames may have
say thank you
um this bill is I think you all know um
relates to the Statewide education
property
tax um and seeks to amend the provisions
that
govern
um
the
um way in which the revenues that are
raised by the
tax uh flow through government channels
back to and then are applied um the
current law um has the collection of the
revenues uh by the
localities towns and
municipalities um throughout the state
unincorporated townships um and
um and then that money is kept retained
locally and uh distributed to school
districts that serve the respective
towns and
municipalities um in the first instance
to cover um costs that are part of the
adequacy uh
costing uh formula and um and then if
there's additional money that is is uh
greater is is left over after that
allocation for adequacy costs that too
is retained locally and if there are
additional Education costs that that
locality is responsible for in its
relationship to school
districts uh it will be applied to those
School costs uh if uh as is the case in
some
instances um there are no other school
costs we've got some townships that
collect the money but have no CH school
children um then the money will be
applied um through bookkeeping
Arrangements uh to um in effect to
offset other costs um in other accounts
uh so that uh those those places show a
negative uh School tax rate to make the
make it all come out right um so uh this
bill 569 would uh change um the
distribution of the revenues after
they're collected and would send all the
revenues back to the uh Department of
Revenue Administration and that's into
the treasury after first a deduction at
the local level for the collection costs
that would be allowed it's not allowed
right now and then uh at the state level
um uh it would it would flow uh into the
uh education fund trust
fund um in addition the bill Pro
provides for um a a more extensive uh
more generous um rebate system for
taxpayers um that would um would
significantly increase the amount of
relief available to uh
lowincome homeowners who are
taxpayers um so that's roughly the bill
um the uh uh context in this for this
bill has been all along
litigation uh challenging the retention
of
excess uh revenues at the local level
um and uh uh trying to and seeking to
persuade the Jud uh the uh courts that
uh that uh this is
unconstitutional and uh must end and a
case to that effect is pending as we
said as we all know I've spoken about
this before it's under
advisement uh before judge ruof um and
uh all arguments have been made all
briefs have been submitted and he uh is
um will release the decision at some
point I hoped we'd all hoped I think
that it would come out earlier than this
and it's critical context for decision-
making related to this bill because it's
not out um and we don't know which way
it will go um and we may may need to
respond to the new reality that that
decision um uh creates for us always
mindful of the fact that appeals can
follow to the uh uh state supreme court
so it may not be fully resolved um and
also mindful of the fact that there's
another lawsuit that also in the hands
of Judge ruof that challenges the entire
adequacy formula and seeks to raise
significantly the state's
obligations um all of that context is to
be developed uh and it's going to change
uh probably um so uh with my
recommendation at this stage in the game
Rel L is uh to um to ask that we support
uh interim study um as a as a a way of
of enabling us to keep our eye on this
ball and to at least have
discussions um as new information comes
out uh that may in the end um have to
take the form of a recommendation for
legislation um in 2 uh for legislation
in 2025 which isn't a bad idea because
that's a budget year and a good time to
adjust things like this um and um and
having this as a uh a way to touch touch
down and and think about the issue is uh
I think a good idea so I hope that we
can go to interim study on this bill for
all the reasons that I just stated
thank you any other
comments okay seeing none we'll close
the work session on HB
569 at this time um I think we can take
a f minute break but I want to stick to
the five minutes let's get back here as
you
together
to
yeah it's there okay all right is
or
all right so it looks like everyone is
back and uh I will open the exec session
ducet thank you Mr chair I would move
uh SB 112 FN with as it stands right now
with amendment number
H okay I think we have to first uh just
introduce the bill I moved the bill move
the bill do I have a second second from
representative Aly and I offer the
amendment 50 uh
H I was about to do that
okay uh do I have a second I'm just
amendment yes
2358 second with a further motion okay
represent straight to what other one
what am I
missing we didn't no I can't because
we we can't go directly to what is it
2344 2444 2 444 because we had the
public hearing on 2358 we need to first
clarification
Mr chair yes I move to substitute
amendment number 2444 h no wait a wait a
minute
wait so I've been told that
um if
everything in 2358 is in
2444 except for um the fix a minor
change then we can introduce that
so represent du set withdraw the motion
on
2358 okay and
now no I don't think we need a second
for that but now you can introduce to
444 thank you Mr chair I I move
amendment
444h I have a second represent Al me
seconds without knowing yet
what okay well we will uh then I'll
recognize representative ducet to tell
us what's in it okay as as we discussed
it IT addresses uh most specifically the
rent the difference uh between the
previous amendment that I offered up and
this uh cleaned up version was I had
inadvertently missed a couple areas in
the statute where it spoke of the
Charities paying
rent and again IT addresses the
racing but most specifically there three
three paragraphs I believe represent of
that I missed where referenced rent in
attention representative
Aly five what turn on your
microphone sorry there seem to be five
paragraphs um
first on line 11
on something that was talking about
charging rent is totally deleted from
the
law and then in
15 uh any agreement entered into by the
charitable
organization deletes any service or
rental
agreement in in in
18 they're um they delete out of um the
circumstances of a loss from games of
chance on the part and any rent paid or
due is
deleted and in
21 there is a totally new
paragraph um all contracts between a
game operator and employer and a
charitable organization to conduct games
of chance under this chapter shall in
contain the following language this
agreement represents the entire
agreement between the parties no charge
or fee of any kind that is not contained
in this agreement shall be paid by the
charity well is and then finally in
25 um no in 25 I guess that's just the
same thing it was before it's yeah
that's renumbered because B is taken out
so they're all renumbered
right any other any other
comments questions okay seeing none with
clerk will take the role
on Amendment 2023
2444 thank you Mr chair it's sb12 FN
ought to pass with this amendment so
it's the amendment that we're voting on
it's correct uh chairman janigan
yes representative Valery yes
representative duet yes representative
spillsbury yes the clerk votes yes uh
representative ner
no representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
Ros
yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shanberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and uh representative Pratt yes it's
voting okay that's the
amendment
now now we'll vote on the bill the vote
the vote then is ought to pass as
amended for sb112
FN uh representative janigian yes repres
representative erery yes representative
ducet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative ple votes yes
Representative nder no representative
sodi yes representative Oris yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes yes representative leapley
yes and representative
Pratt
yes oh 13 14 15 16 17 18 the vote is 18
one and one not
voting
should this go on
consent uh we have one member saying
any fair enough okay all right so it
consent okay I'll close the exec session
sp12 we'll now open the exec session on
HP
paper
um representative shamberg did you who
moved in second I think the
last representative spillsbury thank you
Mr chairman I'd like to make a motion of
inexpedient to legislate on
hp21 do I have
and okay thank you for the
Indulgence all right so representative
spillsbury has made a motion of
second second by represent second who
representative
sod would you like to speak to your
motion does he speak to his motion
amendment
um he does speak he yes speak to his
motion yeah
well my question is I'm perfectly happy
to hold back further discussion till the
Amendments been
made excuse me
but the microphone microphone there's
there's been a motion made and it is itl
unless a motion is made instead that is
ought to pass there cannot be the
amendment well well the amendment
has the application date and the issue
date the effective dates but it is
related to an ought to pass
sorry uh so representative spillsbury do
you want to uh we don't uh we got a
second yes did you want to speak to your
motion I think we've had extensive
discussion during the work session so
I'll hold back in the event there's
anything I need to reut um I reserve
that time
please thank you would anyone like to
speak further on the itl motion
representative Shamburg uh Mr chairman
uh I contest the itl motion the
approach I'd like to express some bullet
points and then go from there
uh I believe that we all can agree that
taxes are our only sustainable source of
revenue for independent states like New
Hampshire and the other 49 states and
that our tax policies are to have a fair
and Level Playing Field for all who pay
taxes and pro business attitudes are
okay if it benefits all
businesses so why do I contest uh this
uh uh
itl uh the Pres Waters Edge has a blind
spot about corporate tax avoidance
techniques that makes the taxpaying
field for domestic businesses of New
Hampshire uh unlevel and at a
competitive
disadvantage due to their relative tax
burden let's go through a few bullet
points uh New Hampshire
adopted worldwide combined reporting in
1981 and utilized it because because it
showed increased transparency and it was
more
Equitable uh the Dr policy of the 1983
through 1986 was driven by political
pressures uh not to
enforce on foreign
Enterprises the majority commission
report
concludes uh that the 1981 through 1986
uh world why combined reporting was
discriminatory and it was basically
based on the political commentary of the
time by the governor that was in the
office and
then
the ways and means commission then and
the legislature adopted Waters Edge only
to
discrimination New Hampshire Supreme
Court acknowledged
this discrimination in the 1999
caterpillar decision we point out that
Waters Edge method was adopted for the
benefit of foreign businesses and how do
I arrive at this
because we have a legal opinion by the
highest court here in the
state prior to 1986 New Hampshire
utilized
worldwide Supreme Court says prior to
1986 New Hampshire utilized worldwide
combined reporting in which the net
income of all members of the unitary
group domestic and foreign was included
in the tax base in 1986 the legislature
Supreme Court says adopted The Waters
Edge method eliminating overseas
business organizations from subjection
to the business profits
tax and the New Hampshire Supreme Court
said the nature of the Waters Edge
formula requires that foreign subsidiary
Aries be treated differently from
domestic
subsidiaries most significantly the
latter's income is subject to taxation
that means the domestics while the
former which is the foreign income is
not and the final statement by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court of 1999 in the
caterpillar
case accordingly while the foreign
members apportionment factors are
excluded Ed from calculation of taxable
profits their income is exempt from the
state business profits
tax almost nine out of 10 jobs in New
Hampshire are provided by domestic
businesses and more than half are small
businesses who pay their full tax
liability while foreign businesses can
avoid tax liability on their New
Hampshire profits through clever while
legal accounting procedure
procedures majority
concedes in their report that transfer
pricing what some might call profit
shifting exists and probably has an
impact on New Hampshire based
businesses waterers Edge violates the
New Hampshire Constitution because it
puts New Hampshire businesses at a
competitive disadvantage and is in is
anti-democratic which is what the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has said in
their words
of it was created for the benefit and it
eliminates overseas businesses from
subjection to business profits
tax little
impact on foreign uh companies as they
uh uh going back a moment the DR had
spoken and had
[Music]
uh the CPA uh organization has spoken
about the the effect
of translations money issues
and there is little impact on foreign
companies now as they must already
prepare all the information required in
the worldwide combined reporting for the
federal government and the
SEC
the Dr there's little impact on the Dr
as New Hampshire law already requires
companies to translate into English and
convert to US
Dollars waterers Edge gives foreign
companies an advantage making New
Hampshire businesses pay more or denying
the state of Revenue or both our
domestic companies pay 100% of their
total tax
liability versus the reported tax
liability from the foreign
multinationals while majority and and
the Dr say they can't measure Revenue
impact it's simple common sense that
broadening tax base will result in more
revenue and it is time to level the
playing
field we have two tiers of
Taxation in the paying of BPT one for
domestic and one for foreign
multinationals as pointed out by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court and I'd like to
do a
little analogy
here should Canadians or British or any
foreign visitors to New Hampshire be
exempt from the state's meals and rooms
tax or the car rental tax how about the
state's tobacco
tax should foreigners be exempt what
about New Hampshire property taxes
should New Hampshire Property Owners
from France or Bermuda or any other
country be exempt from paying New
Hampshire property
taxes would you be willing to pay more
in those New Hampshire taxes to make up
the shortfall the taxes that foreigners
can legally avoid if the laws allowed it
and in today's tax
they
presented conico Phillips owes $390
million in transfer pricing Row in
Louisiana that cononico Phillips engaged
in a series of transactions with
Affiliated parties that were not made at
fair market value leading the company to
under report Louisiana corporate net
income and and failed to pay hundreds of
millions of dollars in state taxes the
Louisiana Department of Revenue told a
state
court I
find as I conclude
here that we presently have two tiers of
Taxation in the paying of BPT one for
domestic one for foreign multinational
companies pointed out by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
democracy is opposed to this there is no
privileged class in the United States or
New Hampshire whether it be for people
or for business
Arrangements thank you
you any other comments
questions representative
spills I think representative already
had his hand up first yeah just just
briefly uh thank representative shamberg
for his advocacy however I think a
couple of uh factual mistakes were made
based upon information that was given
during the commission report uh all
businesses regardless of their status
are treated the same way under rbpt bet
according to Dr testimony in
addition one can um agree that the
caterpillar decision does say
uh that uh the tax code changing to
waterers Edge gives benefit to large
multinationals that's a a function of
scale that's nothing more than that and
we do have cutouts and um divisions and
subdivisions and subdivisions of
subdivisions of our tax code which uh
have existed for a long time indeed um
Professor Hearn that uh representative
Aly brought uh several years ago to this
committee to talk um said that such
activity was perfectly legal so long as
it stayed was perfectly legal rather so
long as it stayed within the same class
of
taxpayer so that you can have a
different tax rate for this person or
this group of people as to this group of
people who though although they may be
similar are different by definition
so I I think some of the uh arguments
that were made were
passionate
however don't really apply to
what worldwide reporting um will do in
my opinion thank you Mr chair
representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman again I don't want
want to repeat the many things that were
said earlier in the work session but
there are several assertions that uh
reut I would encourage everybody to read
the um the commission report in full
even if you haven't had a chance to do
it yet certainly you'll want to do it by
the time this bill comes to the floor in
January you'll find that everything
that's been discussed
was in fact considered and addressed
you'll find that it's been addressed in
a very balanced
way and I would just say uh as an aside
that I've received several compliments
for the quality of the commission's
report in the last
week so I stand by the report the report
clarifies this mky situation from 1981
to
86 and if you look at the legislative
history in which then Governor John
sonunu testified personally in front of
the Ways and Means Committee on two
occasions that's how strongly he felt
about the
bill the dr's explicit policy to not
solicit or
accept a unitary worldwide filing from
any foreign uh
multinational did in fact it created a
de facto discriminatory situation and
when you read the legislative history
repealed
second when it's asserted that water's
edge codifies a real
discrimination and we refer to the 1999
caterpillar case I'd like to just read a
passage from the commission's report
that includes a quotation from that
case so
the New Hampshire Supreme Court's
decision in the 1999 caterpillar case
found that the New Hampshire dr's
differential treatment differential
treatment of foreign Affiliates from us
taxable entities under the waters edge
method was not unconstitutional
discrimination under the federal
Commerce Clause stating quote in sum we
reject the plaintiff's argument that New
Hampshire's apportionment formula UNC
constitutionally discriminates between
foreign and domestic subsidiaries in a
unitary business the nature of the wat's
edge formula requires that foreign
subsidiaries be treated differently from
domestic subsidiaries but most
significantly the latter's income is
not so it goes on to say the plaintiffs
fail however to meet their burden in
proving discrimination although New
Hampshire's unitary apportionment
formula may not a portion income
perfectly the Federal Constitution does
not require mathematical exactitude only
a rough
approximation and the caterpillar Court
the New Hampshire Supreme Court then
quotes the United States Supreme Court's
decision in in
container um Corporation of America and
U and in Barkley's bank and
others so differential
treatment is inherent in taxation
some taxpayers are personal individuals
some are C Corps some are subses some
are
LLCs some invest in hard assets some
don't differential treatment is
throughout the federal and the state tax
code what that case actually stands for
the caterpillar case stands for the fact
that the waters edge method is not
discriminatory in a constitution
sense the assertion was made common
sense that broadening the base will will
result in increasing tax revenue the
commission dug into this and found that
this is
false it is not it is a flawed
assumption to presume that when you
expand the tax base you're going to get
more tax
revenue so let let me try to explain
this
briefly in separate filing each
corporate entity files their own tax
return in Combined reporting which we
have adopted to the water's
edge all activities across the 50 states
are combined into a single return this
is why New Hampshire uses this very
curious formulary
apportionment so when we talk about the
change the legislature made a couple of
years ago from three Factor
to single sales Factor we're talking
about an Arcane
methodology for expanding the base out
to the water's edge out to the 50 states
and then allocating it
back based on sales factor to New
Hampshire so if you eliminate the
waterers Edge limitation and apply
combined reporting worldwide
yes you dramatically expand the base all
of a sudden it becomes relevant what
sell oil made in Britain what they
earned in Netherlands what they earned
in Indonesia etc etc
etc but just
imagine as that denominator mushrooms
out New Hampshire becomes infantes
smaller so just consider this
0.34% of the economy of the United
States right there's 50 states and we're
a small one so it's a third of a
percent and so even when we apply
Water's
Edge if you've got a company that's
doing business in 50 states you might
just say more or less roughly they're
going to allocate only 34% of that
business activity in New Hampshire that
of course is going to vary very much on
where they're based and how they're
doing business but it does not
necessarily generate more income because
you expand the base and you contract the
numerator and you may end up in the same
place or even worse than where you
were I hate to labor through that but
the reason you need the reason you
needed a commission and the reason you
complicated final
comment
what the federal government does in the
so-called separate filing system is they
deploy a methodology called arms
length and they have a a elaborate set
of
regulations that give them the ability
to insist that a foreign company that is
using transfer
pricing use reasonable prices and in the
audit process if they find that a
corporation has been making transfer
payments that are
not as two different entities at arms
length would do like two unaffiliated
corporations in a contractual
relationship would
do then they their regulations give them
the the authority to um to correct it to
insist in uh revised tax return to
enforce the
law New Hampshire gets the benefit out
of that activity
so the kico case that was cited is an
example of that the reason that that was
in the court was because it was an
enforcement action to insist that arms
length pricing adjustments be
made it's actually an example of getting
into the specific tax return of a
specific T tax Filer and correcting
it
so the
assertion that there are two tiers of
Taxation is just not
valid there may be different outcomes
there may be different
circumstances some companies may make
certain transfers and some may even
abuse them but the idea that our system
is fundamentally set up so that there's
supportable thank you representative
spillsbury and and thank you for all the
work you you've done in this commission
and the Deep dive that you've done there
representative PL yes I did not
understand one thing you said
representative spillsbury I'll use an
example hypothetical let's say a
business is doing a million dollars of
sales in New Hampshire and they're doing
500 million Nationwide so it would be 1
million over 500 million time uh uh time
times the tax tax burden that would come
out Water's Edge if you go to uh
worldwide you still have the 1 million
New Hampshire but you might have three
billion uh internationally so it's much
but but that percentage would be
therefore much reduced and you don't
wind up necessarily with more tax that
is that
correct the one thing you said was that
is precisely correct because as you
expand the tax base you dilute the
numerator and you end up with something
that is no greater because you have a
smaller share of a larger pool you said
reduce the numerator that I did not
accept but you you it's it's diluted
because you have a bigger base
the denominator grows the numerator
strengths and so the uh the fraction
becomes dramatically smart I didn't
understand how the numerator shrinks
because it's the same revenues in New
Hampshire either way sales in New
way you're yes mathematics and I'm I'm
thinking of the equation in two
different ways but you're right it's
it's the it's the profits earned in New
Hampshire div Ed by under our current
system the profits earned across 50
states and if this was implemented it's
the same numerator in terms of profits
against a much larger denominator so
that the percentage of the factor is
dramatically
reduced Mr chairman I'm
sorry uh yes representative
Aly thank
you on
the problem because of the transfer
pricing is that the profits that you're
talking about
on are reduced artificially because
Microsoft or Amazon which are two of the
ones that play with this in this field
on have sent their um sent their
intellectual property at a reduced rate
to their subsidiary in Ireland or the
Virgin Islands or
wherever uh where there is a
05%
tax uh and that has reduced their
profits everywhere
else and
um that is an issue which
is the are trying to work on especially
in Europe and some other countries on
not so much in the United States and I
believe that is partly because the IRS
for years has been starved of Revenue of
money and has has red had to reduce a
lot of what it was doing especially
going after very wealthy corporations
that it requires a lot of money to go
after they are now starting to do that
they may start working on this but
um
issue and because we have
just on against the will of both sides
of our committee on moved to a system
that starts this next next year I
believe of um or maybe it's start it
started this year actually we'll see it
next year uh single sales Factor based
only on sales in a state with an elderly
population and a lot of businesses that
specialize in selling outside the state
instead of inside the state uh we are
going to be in considerable amount of
trouble and I want to
keep every idea even if they aren't
fully developed yet on that might help
us to survive that alive so I'm going to
be voting against the itl thank
you representa spilburg I think much of
what representative Amy has just said is
valid but it doesn't change my
conclusion um and and I you've just just
um zeroed in again on the single sales
factor and I am actually a little
concerned as I think quietly listening
to The Exchange I had with
clear where where you have three factors
what you do is you take that mix right
of assets and employment and and sales
so we're now moving into single sales
Factor let's focus on that but you
basically are asking them to do is to
measure their sales in New
Hampshire that's the numerator not the
profits sales in New Hampshire to the
sales across the 50 states and if we go
forward with Worldwide combined to the
sales
worldwide and that's the ratio that you
then multiply against their worldwide
profits to determine what portion of
those profits are attributable to New
Hampshire and subject to New Hampshire
tax so the RTI ratio is sales
activity multiplied against worldwide
profits to determine the New Hampshire
taxable
profit represent shamber just to finish
this up uh when representative oy was
talking
about all these experts that came
in and gave their
explanations I appreciate that but that
is not what the legal position was by
the New Hampshire Supreme
Court
okay and in our commission I uh I uh
called my good friend from Charleston he
should have been a coach coach
spillsbury because at times uh I believe
that there's some mystery Direction
here
uh in contrast to what this New
Hampshire Supreme Court pointed out in
the
summation
the foreign
multinationals were
arguing about dividends and
royalties not their entire
income and it's only the US
multinationals
that are taxed on the dividends and
royalties sent over or sent back from
their
subsidiaries anywhere else in the world
about and when it is
said
that there was no discriminatory Factor
this is what they're talking about the
Supreme Court is talking
about that they were not being treated
any differently than any
other uh domestic business that receives
dividends and
royalties because this was value added
reported I hope
that we will eventually be able to make
some positions on
the floor of the house come January
which I think would we would find very
interesting and try and
explain
to 480 or 380 other Representatives what
this is about and uh hope you'll give us
you yes representative elberger thank
you Mr chairman um representative
spillsbury pointed out that New
Hampshire economy is about a third of 1%
of the United States uh
economy we have fewer than a million and
a half people here out of
a uh total population of over 300
million if I remember
correctly we don't have a problem saying
even so we want a distinction such as
being the first in the nation in
presidential primaries and that's great
it the fact that we may be a small state
with a small economy doesn't mitigate
the factor that we have the right and
responsibility to look at what that
means um there are two issues there's
the tax
revenue and as Ways and Means Committee
members we are charged with looking at
that revenue and what it uh will do at
uh in terms of funding our state for the
coming
years as Representatives we're also
charged with I believe we're charged
with dealing with the issue of fairness
and whether that means that uh tax
revenues might drop or
increase if we switched to a nonwater
edge way of looking at things the issue
is we need to be fair and not put our
own State companies at a disadvantage in
access to
tax uh tax
law sometimes the law is wrong uh the
country was founded on the belief that
the British law was wrong and we needed
to set up our own laws oh not more than
a hundred years ago just over a 100
years ago women by law were not allowed
to vote
we change laws as we see we need to
to ensure fairness and Equity of access
not necessarily of outcome but of access
and I believe that that's an equal part
of what this
entails in addition to the issue of what
the revenue would be thank
else all right if if I can one represent
I just want to be very
brief I am one of those who applauds New
Hampshire's willingness to be courageous
and different and uh you know we can all
come up with many examples and defend
them but we're talking about taxation
we're talking about multinational
situation we're talking about
enforcement hurdles talking about filing
complications talking about auditing
problems and we're going to go about
this in a way that delinks us from the
Internal Revenue code I think that's
unwise so we can choose when it's right
to be different and we can choose when
you all right seeing uh no more we will
uh ask the clerk to take the role I
shall do so this is an itl motion
chairman
janigian yes represent oler no I mean
yes itl I'll take that
first representative du duet yes
represent spillsbury yes representative
PL votes yes representative ner yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative rord yes
representative
Aly no representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative fellows no
representative Bolton no Representative
elberger no Representative leapley
no uh representative uh
Pratt
yes okay that's 10 to
nine one not voting that goes on the
okay close the executive session on HB
1221 we'll now open the exec session on
Al I move itl on House Bill 192 FN and
want to speak to my motion all right do
I have a second second by representative
ducet representative omy thank you um
this bill was written to modify the
interest in dividends tax RSA
77 but I've been changing it but in
hb2 uh RSA 77 was repealed as of the end
of
2024 therefore the full committee was
unanimous in voting itl a new 21st
century version will be heard in 2024
when the need for the taxes
foregone uh to
avoid uh further property tax increases
will uh start to become
evident I I obviously need to work on
that a
little thank you any other comments or
questions all right the clerk will take
the
role cre the sheets on it since I
misplaced
it on the motion HB 192 FN motion is to
itl uh representative janig chairman Jan
janigian yes representative Valery yes
represent deset yes representative
spillsbury yes representative PL votes
yes representative ner yes
representative sodi yes represent ores
yes representative roord yes
representative
Aly representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shanberg yes representative fellos yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and representative Pratt yes the vote is
voting this this will be put on this
will get put on consent unless we have
an
objection I yes since you're killing it
yes if you weren't it's money okay oh I
see what you're saying okay so it it can
consent
um okay we close the exec session on
192 we'll now open the exec session on
HB 569 relative to the State education
property
tax representative
569 do I have a
second second I just okay second
representative
PL any discussion do you want to speak
to your motion just say a few words this
uh bill is we all know
addresses the uh uh Statewide education
property tax and provides for its uh the
uh collection then payment of the
revenues into the state level and then
dispersement out for educational
purposes it also uh strengthens extends
U makes more generous the uh rebate Pro
program for um property
taxpayers locally whose income is low
and U it uh is and will be it's uh the
need for it uh stems from constitutional
law
considerations there's a case right now
pending uh decision that will address uh
the Constitutional issue and um
hopefully it will come soon but in in
its absence I I'm uh I believe the best
uh best uh method of uh addressing this
bill is to hold it and and place it into
an interim study mode uh then that's why
I'm moving
that thank you any
other questions
comments seeing none the clerk will call
the role thank you Mr chair um chairman
janigan yes representative valy yes
represent duet yes representative
spillsbury yes represent PL votes yes
representative n yes representative sodi
yes representative ORS yes represent
roer yes RM
sorry are you not in the
[Laughter]
military sorry represent Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
strongberg yes representative fellow yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and representative Pratt yes 19 to zero
one not
voting all right if there's no
objections we'll put it on
consent all right put it on consent Mr
chair
yes since I've been asked to record this
can I just establish who will write the
report and or any Minority Report on
each of these four bills yes so I'll
assume that spillsbury and shamberg will
write a majority and Minority Report for
121 right good okay and representative
Report yes represent I'm not allowed to
because I'm just a substitute okay so
there's no Minority Report none okay
Aly yes represent Al me good gave you I
just need to massage it a little and for
Ames
Monday all
right representative spilsbury you'll
okay okay that uh that concludes our
work today and really the work for the
year um this oh did I not exec we'll end
the exec session if I didn't end on the
uh 569 but this uh concludes our work
for for this year and um we'll see you
all next year probably January 3rd I
guess is our first host session so like
to uh give a special thanks to our chair
acting chair um representative janigian
who's stepped into this role
unexpectedly and has Managed IT superbly
so thank you very much appreciate it
thank
you